a sociologist studying fertility in
france and switzerland wanted to test if
there was a difference in the average
number of babies women in each country
have
the sociologists obtained a random
sample of women from each country here
are the results of their test so you can
see a hundred percent sample from france
100 sample from switzerland they
actually don't have to be the same
sample size we have our sample means our
sample standard deviations you have the
standard error of the mean which for
each sample would be our estimate of the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the sample mean
and here it says t-test for the means of
these different populations being
different and just to make sure we can
make sense of this let's just remind
ourselves what's going on the null
hypothesis is that there's no difference
in the mean number of babies that women
in france have versus the mean number of
babies that women in switzerland have
that would be our null hypothesis the no
news here hypothesis and our alternative
would be that they are different and
that's what we have right over here it's
a t-test to see if we have evidence that
would suggest our alternative hypothesis
and so what we do is we assume the null
hypothesis from that you're able to
calculate a t statistic and then from
that t statistic and the degrees of
freedom you are able to calculate a
p-value and if that p-value is below
your significance level then you say hey
this was pretty unlikely scenario let me
reject the null hypothesis which would
suggest the alternative
but if your p-value is greater than your
significance level then you would fail
to reject your null hypothesis and so
you would not have sufficient evidence
to conclude the alternative so what's
going on over here you really just have
to compare this value to this value it
says at the alpha is equal to 0.05 level
of significance is there sufficient
evidence to conclude that there is a
difference in the average number of
babies women in each country have
well we can see that
our p-value 0.13 is greater than our
alpha value 0.05 and so because of that
we fail
to
reject
our null hypothesis and to answer their
question no there is not sufficient
evidence to conclude that there is a
difference there is not sufficient
evidence to reject the null hypothesis
and suggest the alternative